[Music]
well brand-new New York Times editorial
board member sarahx Jang has become an
inspirational figure on the left an
unlikely one her example shows that
despising people for their skin colour
is not only no barrier to career success
it helps as long as you despise the
right group and then invent new
definitions for words like racism to
obscure what you're really saying but
Jang and people like Jang don't emerge
organically they are products of an
education system here in America that
trains people to think this way and the
wrecking the country in so doing Heather
McDonald is a contributing editor at
City Journal she's followed this
phenomenon very closely and she joins us
tonight Heather thank you for coming on
so how did this happen so I I mean
nobody is they used to say when I was a
child nobody is born a bigot it's
something that you learn we're creating
a whole new generation of them why and
how is this happening
well there's a multi-million dollar
diversity bureaucracy on most college
campuses today that is dedicated to the
very propositions that Sarah Jang
embodies things like whiteness is a
source of all evil in the world lethal
to people of color a contempt for
objectivity and truth seeking a belief
that all females exist in a state of
oppression by rape culture this
diversity bureaucracy hits students with
this ideology from the moment they step
foot on campus putting them in the
throes of a very terrible delusion
American college students are the most
privileged human beings in history
simply by virtue of their access to vast
educational opportunities and yet
college presidents on down tell them
that they are the subject of ubiquitous
racism on the college campus itself so
why I mean that's it's clearly just
literally destroying the country and a
generation of promising young people and
yet the rest of us who are not young are
subsidizing it either directly through
tuition or donation
or indirectly through through our taxes
why are we do are we all playing along
with this I think people still don't get
what's going on I would hope that with
with knowledge would come power in
action people basically send their kids
off to school and have trust that these
are the colleges that they remember from
growing up they are not they are hatred
machines as you say Tucker
there is a conveyer belt from the
Academy into the world at large into
corporations into the media as you say
also Sara John was treated with a big
yawn by the mainstream media and by
liberal institutions because her
ideology is banal it is simply the state
of the art right now whether it's the
New York Times CNN or The Washington
Post people have to stop giving money to
colleges don't don't give it to your
alma mater unless you've done very
thorough due diligence inquiry and they
need to start standing up for this lie
that America is a fundamentally bigoted
place because we are we are toying with
real civil war I think at this point
exactly and we're funding and we should
stop because it's cancer Heather thank
you for so crisply articulating all that
I appreciate it great to see you Tucker